welcome
welcome so exciting to see you all here
it's great to see everybody and have
everybody thank you so much for coming
out on this cold day
um I'm Stephen pity professor of History
American studies and ERM and director of
Yale center for the study of race
indigenadian transnational migration
which has helped to support this event
um really happy to remind you at the
outset that we in New Haven here are
sitting on territory that's long been
the home of Mohegan Mashantucket Pequot
Eastern Pequot scatter Coke Golden Hill
pagaset Niantic Quinnipiac and other
Algonquin speaking people peoples and
then we continue ourselves to be
revitalized by their survivants every
day we're delighted to help support this
event as ritm along uh with Ezra Stiles
college at Yale and I want to thank a
number of people for making this happen
Kathy Dunn and Mark Levinson in Ezra
Styles Nicole Edwards and Maggie Katz
and Mary Taylor Lewis and Victoria Stone
Cadena in ritm and the Andrew W Mellon
foundation for providing the funding
that made this event possible
let me also recognize that we have today
with us the poet laureate of the state
of Connecticut Antoinette brim Bell
um who's here and who has joined us
today uh thank you Antoinette for being
here
I've also asked before we turn the
podium uh so-called over to our our
guests here in front to just say a few
logistical words first I want to make
sure everybody knows that the Yale
University Art Gallery closes at 5 PM so
if that if you left any belongings in
the Lockers in the art gallery you're
going to need to retrieve those now or
at least before five o'clock because the
gallery will be closed you won't be able
to get back into the lockers for your
keys your wallets your jackets and all
the rest so please do go fetch things
from the lockers before five there's
really no way to open up the building
after that time second although I'm not
demonstrating it now the art gallery
gallery requires the use of face masks
in this space so please please remain
masked throughout the event while you're
here
um uh that's very important to our
speaker and to all of us
um third I wanted just to alert
everybody that this event is being
recorded you'll see there's a camera in
the back and there may be other cameras
so just I wanted to make sure that
you're aware of that
um finally
um logistically we're going to open um
everything the program up for audience
questions in the last roughly 20 minutes
of our event today so please when that
time comes if you do have a question use
the microphone which I think will be
circulating so that our guest can hear
you and so that everybody else in the
room can hear you as well I'll add
um that uh at the very very end we'll
have time for audience members to come
forward to request a book signing by Ada
Limon at the end of the event around six
o'clock it's going to be pretty short we
have a hard stop it'll be a pretty quick
session but we'll do our best to
accommodate as many people uh as want to
have a book signed and I'm going to get
out of the way
um but as I uh leave the stage I have
the pleasure of introducing the real
host of this event Professor Alicia
Schmidt Camacho
um
[Applause]
whom I know quite well
um at Yale Professor Schmidt garmacho is
the head of Ezra Stiles College she's a
faculty member in and former chair of
the a program in ethnicity race and
migration and she's a scholar whose work
has focused on migration the U.S Mexico
border latinx studies and other topics
and Fields I'll avoid staying too long
to sing her Praises but I'll just invite
you to join me in thanking and welcoming
Alicia Schmidt Camacho
[Applause]
okay this is really beautiful
I have the joyful task of introducing
the 24th Poet Laureate era Limon and
opening our conversation this afternoon
what a gift it is to be together
thank you Ada Limon for giving us this
occasion to gather in community
in the service of poetry
era Limon as you know grew up in Sonoma
California and resides in Lexington
Kentucky where she writes and teaches
she's the author of six books of poetry
including the carrying which won the
national books critics Circle award for
poetry
her new
um
she hosted the celebrated poetry podcast
the Slowdown and her new book of poetry
the herding kind is out now from
milkweed editions and is a candidate for
the 2023 Southern book prize
and I want to thank my colleagues at the
Yale center for the study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
for the students and colleagues in Ezra
Styles and around campus and ethnicity
race and migration in other communities
who've shared the love of poetry with me
and shared so much with me
and I want to give special thanks also
to our hosts the Yale University Art
Gallery for welcoming us and I want to
welcome thank someone else who's not
here Von Fielder representative for Ada
Limon who runs something called the
field office where she makes the most
Exquisite books and broadsides please
look for it
before we begin I want to mention how
marvelous it has been to prepare for
this occasion
Ada your arrival has helped give us a
chance to gather and be in celebration
something we needed
we in Ezra Styles we began talking about
inviting Ada Limon some time ago and
since we announced the visit I keep
hearing testimony from so many people
about all that her poetry and her work
has represented for them
and in the week between drafting my
message of inquiry and actually sending
it
era Limon was named the poet laureate
but you were our lawyer at first
and I don't remember many moments where
I actually could trust my government's
judgment
least of all in anything as important as
poetry and art
but the office of poet laureate housed
in the Library of Congress may be the
one Authority in the land to whom I will
happily submit
and it was beautiful to watch The
Librarian of Congress
Carla Hayden named you to this post Ada
to talk about your poetry being a force
in the world one that Fosters connection
intimacy healing one that invites us to
the table
and Tracy K Smith also a poet laureate
called you a poet of ecstatic Revelation
whose poems offer deep wisdom and Urgent
vulnerability driven by language that
feels not only beautiful but permanent
and powerfully wrought like a mountain
that is certainly how we've experienced
your work here your poems have been
integral to our life as a community
they've given us a language for finding
one another for coming together in
difficult moments for imagining living
beyond
the time of pandemic for imagining how
we can thrive
thank you
and so I'm going to begin move over here
so that we can begin more conversation
and Ada come face out to see all of you
foreign
[Applause]
so
my favorite moment
when you were at the Library of Congress
um was right at the beginning after
you've been announced and you stepped up
and you greeted everyone you sort of
announced your arrival in this post and
you said
we rolled deep
We Roll deep
and it was a moment of recognition for
me
because I think again like what are we
trying to do here we're trying to gather
ourselves together to build power
together
in something precious
precious the way that art is precious
the way that art accompanies us in our
lives when we need it
how do we be together
and so it struck me that we rolled deep
was kind of an artist statement and well
as well as a mission for you in this
role of
Poet Laureate and I wanted to ask you
about that because
in your art you contain multitudes you
know
your art brings multitudes
um
I love that thank you so much for that
um I feel like it's first of all a
beautiful introduction and just such a
gift to be here with you all thank you
for coming out
um and uh I think I think one of the
things that I've always sort of
pushed against is that sort of myth that
we make art alone
um and that that myth that like one
person Rises
um
I just don't believe it uh I I have
always believed that we make art and
Community
even if what we're working on aren't
exactly collaborations what we're
actually doing is often reaching out to
one another and saying hey will you read
this one poem or hey will you listen to
this song or hey will you come to this
this play or you know you're having this
you're always reaching out and you're
always getting that support from the
people you need and um that to me is all
part of the art making process and so
when I'm saying We Roll deep I really do
believe that we do that even if when
even if deep means two people
right I'm not saying you have to you
know have this huge network of people to
support you sometimes you need one other
person
you know that just says yeah yeah this
this keep doing it you know and
sometimes they don't even need to
critique it sometimes it's better if
they don't
sometimes it's just better if they say
yes keep going but I think it's I think
it's important to remember that
um sometimes it can look like one person
is doing a lot and in reality a lot of
people are doing a lot of things and all
of us are in community
thank you
and Ada as I told you earlier today at
the onset of the pandemic we really had
to reinvent the university you know for
the conditions of separation and
isolation and that's really hard
and
one thing that arose I think in many
parts
of the world where these chain mail
messages
and I was lucky to be receiving messages
with poetry and then the instruction
would be here's this poem now you have
to send your poem to these 10 other
strangers and
it went around and it was International
and
eventually you know I was getting
repeats from people so it was clear that
like this was doing some great work
right
and your poems were there more often
than not the one that I always put out
there was dead stars one really works on
me but
um then when I took up my post as the
head of college and was writing a Weekly
Newsletter my Dean Dean Temple's here
with me we were trying to figure out how
to build connections to students and to
build a sense of community across many
time zones for students who were in
spaces where you know
maybe learning was the last thing on
their mind during their especially
difficult days how do we be present for
them how do we invite them in
and how do we have the conversations
about things that we really need to talk
about right
and again your poems gave me away
to give a piece of Something Beautiful
something to think about but most often
really invite people in
and I put a lot of different poems out
there and I did notice that the ones
from you I kept hearing more and then
also when students were sending me ideas
for poems that they wanted to hear
they were sending me your poems I love
that and I've been thinking a lot about
that
because there's a lot of really very
beautiful poetry out there right but
there was something about
your attention
to the world
your attention to emotion you know that
really I felt like was what we needed in
the University at that moment right the
University
sometimes presents itself as a space of
learning where we leave
emotions aside to achieve or to
accomplish right and we receive wisdom
but
in your poetry there's the knowledge
that we're really struggling sometimes
you know
that we're kind of a mess
and that we might hurt and that that's
actually
the best we can be right now is true
with what we're feeling and it felt to
me like the students were
able to commune with you and then
through you me because you made that
space and poetry made that space and um
I wanted to ask you to maybe think about
the way you think about emotions and
also that I know you're a teacher how
you might think about the teaching in
your poetry
yeah thank you that was really beautiful
I think that one of the big things for
me is that there's um
people will say things like oh poetry
can do this or poetry you can do that or
you should read it read a poem it'll
make you feel hopeful and we were
laughing today it's like well that
depends on what poem you read
you know because if you read Philip
Larkin's poem about the groundhog
I don't think you're going to feel very
hopeful after that poem and so I think
that there's a lot of sort of
misconceptions about what poetry can do
and I think it's only because it limits
it you know and for me I think it's not
just that it makes you feel one thing or
that or another makes you feel happy
makes you feel hopeful makes you
reconnect with some sort of
um
you know long-lost feeling that you have
to dig up from someplace you've been
suppressing it I think it's really that
it just makes you feel
and I think that is important
and I think that we've been living at a
time where we've just had to numb so
much of our lives and a lot of that is
is necessary like I don't even think
that's necessarily a bad thing that
we've had to numb things because it's
really hard to feel all the things that
we've been feeling
um and I think poetry is that way of
sort of tapping into that and being able
to like oh right I am a thinking feeling
human being going through all of these
things I have this com these complex
emotions working within me and in doing
so feeling like oh I'm reminded that
this is what being a human being is like
it's not just putting my head down and
getting from point A to point B you know
it's not just survival
can it also be flourishing you know can
it also be witnessing
experiencing
and I think that's a big part of what
I've been trying to do with my work for
a long time
which is like can it help me each time I
write a poem
or recommit in some way to the world
that each time I go to the page I'm
saying here I am
I'm here
you know it's like a
you know a map
that says you are here you know each
poem is like you are here
and uh that I think feels just as
important as a as you know something
that might perhaps contain more answers
or wisdom more knowledge poetry doesn't
you know doesn't do that it contains
more questions you know and the
questions lead to more questions
and in that it's just sort of accepting
that that fluidness of life and that you
know this amorphous aspect of changing
and growing and and being more in tune
with ourselves
you know the great poet CD Wright said
you know the goal is not is not to make
a story but to experience the whole mess
and I think about that all the time
because we we kind of want to do sort of
do this tidy thing in our head this is
what happened
but really
you know our jobs are just to experience
the whole mess
the thing pretty extraordinary happens
in the way you guide us to that
mess right and you hold us there it
seems to me that
it's no accident that
the volume before the herding kind was
the carrying right there's
so much
required of us to be caring and yet that
caring is also the richness of life
right and that's our vehicle for joy and
fullness right that's
capacity to do that and
and I just
you know like many people I went to
funerals in the last few years that's
right we've seen a lot of violence in
the last few years
intimate violence as as well as
terrifying Terror in the world right
and one of the things that I noticed is
that it's like a saying now to say
there are no words when you're greeting
someone in grief but of course there are
you know and that always seemed to me
like why are we letting ourselves off
the hook right how do we be present in
these moments how do we actually create
the language we need so again I turn to
your poetry
because I think
you're attentive to wear fear atomizes
us and pushes away from each other
and you're not afraid to look for
language for The Ensemble to gesture
towards what is unstable and to leave it
there for us to disentangle and so I'm
going to give you an example of a line
that lives with me now it's in my it's
part of my mental and spiritual
Furniture again from dead stars I am a
hearth of spiders these days a nest of
trying
there's so much happening there
and earlier today when we were talking
with students
it's beautiful you use the word
ongoingness as a thing as something that
is both what we are tasked to do that is
also glorious what a gift to experience
our own ongoingness so again I just want
to invite you to talk about
you're tapping into something for us
there and it's a lesson but it's a
lesson that seems hard one so I'm going
to ask you how to how you've thought
about that
yeah
um thank you for that I feel like
there's a
there's so much grief and and processing
that we have to do
in to just live
to just live and it's funny because we
can think that we don't have to grieve
right and then like six months later
you're like oh
what's happening you're like oh right
I am grieving this thing that I didn't
go through
you know or that I thought I was fine or
you know and I think that that keeps
happening to us and there's not just the
grief of the pandemic but there's the
you know there's the species loss and
the plant loss and like the planet
itself
um grieving from our own harm and all of
these things that we're processing and I
think it's um
like anyone else it's very easy for me
to shut down to it you know I'd much
rather you have a drink and binge watch
Netflix than think about all the wounds
I want to carry you know but at the same
time I know that if I'm not working
through some of that stuff not all of it
I can't take it all on
but maybe a little part of it a little
edge of it
and if I can kind of tease it out and
work through it a little bit I know that
I will be
saner and I know that I can be kinder to
other people because I will it's my way
of being kind to myself
and so in a lot of ways I think about
um
there's this great Buddhist monk named
llama Rod Owens I don't know if you know
him and he he has this he talks about
that the goal is longevity
and I think about that a lot because
it's very easy to think like I just need
to get through the day
or I just need to get to two to five
o'clock or whatever it is or to get
Hannah's Final in or to get this project
done and then I can start to think about
other things
and he talks about longevity because the
way that we burn out right the way that
we burn out as artists or what or
whoever we are is by
not dealing with some of these big
ticket topics
and just trying to sort of suppress them
or trying to take them all on at once
and then wondering why in a year from
now we can't write anything you know so
I keep thinking about
a lot of my poems are also a way of
caretaking myself
um
and a way of recognizing that my need to
be
alive and witnessing the world is a need
that I would like to continue
and so sometimes when I'm going into the
well
I have to give myself that ladder out
like I have to be like okay this is you
know you've gone you've spent some time
down here good for you now where are the
stairs
you know and I um I think that's really
important for us not only as artists but
as human beings it's like it's one thing
to to face the darkness but it's another
thing to know that um
you know you have you have a way out
um and I think that that that's very
much a part of me making poems that it's
not just about
um I love when they land with someone
and how they land with someone and
hearing how it's affected it's like it's
deeply emotional to me and a little
overwhelming sometimes to hear someone
say oh this moved me I love that
um but oftentimes when I'm making the
poem I'm not thinking about that I'm
thinking of how do I get really honest
with myself
and how do I say something that feels
unsayable
and then how do I create spaces within
the poem where I can breathe a little
bit
you know and um
and some of those poems you know turn
towards the light and some of them turn
away but hopefully there's enough
balance in them as they go that uh that
it feels like there's a sense of
wholeness there
you've used the word a couple times in
this conversation witnessing yeah and it
is there in your early poems
but it is sort of
structuring idea in the hurting kind
and
I think of it as something that you
have developed as a
um
vocation in this work that you do
and I was thinking about
what's
how you think about that term because
there's so much in the hurting kind
about
being a witness and not needing the
things you're looking at to give you
anything back in fact the fox is
completely indifferent the birds are
indifferent right and but the task of
witness is a constant and it's a process
that is revelatory for you and
and for us by reading and the witnessing
is so often directed toward the
non-human world
and is often a way of affiliating us
with the non-human world and you've just
spoken about that a bit um and then I
thought there's something else that's
really powerful about your concept of
witness that I think we forget we think
Witnesses
Is Us
seeing
attending and speaking to something but
do you really want us to be there with
our bodies you're attentive to the bot
the body is a witness right you know the
body has is to be present in the body
experiences the world and we have to
make space for how the body is in the
world
and there's a beautiful moment where the
body is fragile and you say the body is
so body and it is so funny as a person
who lives in a body that is a bit
puzzling something yeah oh my God yeah
but I just wanted to ask you to talk a
little bit about witness and what that
yeah for you I love that question and
the many different layers to it I feel
like there's um
you know to start with the body
it sounds like a creely poem
he has that line right about the body
the plan is the body the plan is the
body he just says that over and over
again it's wonderful
um
I think that there's um there's a level
in which um
I because I have an undergraduate degree
in theater I was I was taught about the
body as a tool and the body as
instrument
um and so when I moved to poetry breath
work and you know sort of the
is-ness of the body within the poems
because that's how you make things was
to was to um
to encourage the body's presence to be
present within the body but I too and I
love that word you said puzzling
a body that can sometimes be buzzling
who doesn't have a body that can
sometimes be puzzling
especially at a time where like you know
they ask us about symptoms it's like I
think I've had every symptom
my friend Kristen dunback was a
wonderful non-fiction writer said she
just wants to write a book called
symptoms which is just all like all the
symptoms that all of her female like all
of her women friends like send her just
on a on like a daily basis like so what
are the symptoms today
um and I so I think that you know I live
in a body that's that's you know
oftentimes in pain I have um I have I
try not to say the word chronic pain
because I believe it will someday go
away
um
but I do you know I I do live in a body
that's a little more difficult to get
around sometimes than others
um and I experience vertigo and I have
scoliosis so there's these just things
that kind of keep me from being
completely uh totally free in the body
and so I think when I write my poems and
I think about witnessing I'm thinking
about how is how are all the senses and
I can't witness without being like well
if I'm witnessing and I'm taking a deep
breath
you think oh my back hurts a little bit
when I take a deep breath right there's
all these other things that are in the
body when I do that you know I used to
love it when
you know meditation teachers would say
like
um you know just sit and be in the body
and I'd be like well what if the body is
the problem
you know I was like the one person on
Zoom I was like when the one person on
Zoom that I was like oh finally I just
get to be ahead I've always only wanted
to be ahead
I was like this is amazing
you know now it's like okay body we can
do it
um and so I think that that witnessing
had to include the blood the body you
know every part of it
um and there's this funny when you talk
about like that moment about it because
I remember
in one of the poems when I was writing
the herding kind having this moment of
being like
you know it was it was during when we
were all isolate really isolating and we
weren't so I wasn't even it was just
waving to neighbors and
um
feeling very alone and I just literally
just like crawled on my belly onto the
grass and just like laid there and got
really low and I and I kept thinking
this is like low snake energy and I was
like I'm just gonna have some low snake
energy and see what happens but it was
this way of being like okay you know how
do I witness from down here how do I
witness from up here and then I thought
about all the different animals and
birds that are like seeing what they're
seeing from their different viewpoints
right the birds that kind of twist their
head and turn on look at you upside down
you know and the trees how they're
witnessing you from up there but they're
also we're standing on their Roots you
know they're just underneath us all the
time and um all those different
viewpoints and how that connects Us and
how strange it is that we think it's
like just the the poet going into the
world being like I see this yeah right
but that's not how poetry happens it's
often like oh I wonder what that what
that bird thinks of me you know
um and uh and that that all of that is
in tandem with of course like how the
body is also nature and is also animal
and that feels very important to
my work and my and my life
[Music]
yes I will read for you what if I said
no I would like
be like yes of course I will read
I shall go to the podium it's like a
whole different area over there
turn this off
can you hear me okay
great
we were laughing that I was like well we
could just kind of you know take it as
it goes and then we realized that we're
about we were both um talkers
so we're like no we we actually need to
keep an eye on the time
to be respectful of everyone
um
so I thought I would read I think it's
going to be I'm going to guess 10 poems
um I'm going to give you that number
to make you feel a little
modicum of control
in the otherwise uncontrollable
situation that is the poetry reading
you can count down or count up however
you feel like I'm going to start with
this poem
um that is in the carrying
um
which is uh
I think speaks to some of the things we
were just talking about in that
conversation with sort of looking for
some ways to caretake the self
but also sort of denying a kind of
wisdom
and I'd like to tell you a little bit of
the background of it um which is that it
is a poem that I initially wanted it to
start the collection and my editor was
like no
you're gonna you're that's a lot
um and then also I'll say that it was a
prompt that was uh
it was the Academy of American poets
asked me to write a poem that would be
the first poem of the year
in 2016.
um
and of course it was how do you do that
they're like just set the tone for the
year
so
and it was a hard year and so this is
this is this is the this is the poem
the leash
after the birthing of bombs of forks and
fear the Frantic automatic weapons
unleashed the spray of bullets into a
crowd holding hands that brute sky
opening in a slate metal mall that
swallows only the unsayable in each of
us
what's left
even the hidden nowhere river is
poisoned orange and acidic by a coal
mine
how can you not fear Humanity want to
lick the creek bottom dry to suck the
deadly water up into your own lungs like
Venom
reader I want to say don't die
even when silvery fish after fish comes
back Belly Up and the country plummets
into a crepitating crater of hatred
isn't there still something singing
the truth is
I don't know
but sometimes I swear I hear it the
wound closing like a rusted over garage
door and I can still move my living
limbs into the world without too much
pain can still Marvel at how the dog
runs straight toward the pickup trucks
break nicking down the road because she
thinks she loves them
because she's sure without a doubt that
the loud roaring things will love her
back
her soft small self alive with desire to
share her goddamn enthusiasm
until I yank the leash back to save her
because I want her to survive forever
don't die I say
and we decide to walk for a bit longer
Sterling's high and fevered above us
winter coming to lay her cold corpse
down upon this little plot of Earth
perhaps we are always hurtling our
bodies toward the thing that will
obliterate us begging for Love from the
speeding passage of time
and so maybe
like the dog obedient at my heels
we can walk together peacefully at least
until the next truck comes
[Applause]
thank you
thank you my dog loves poems about her
she's a pug so you know she's
everyone's like oh pugs are so funny I
was like no they're funny because
they're very serious
and this is a poem that I wrote for my
mother
um
and uh one of the students I met with
today said that she read this book with
her mother and so um thought I would
read this
um
it's a poem that began with the ending
for me and then I built backwards which
I think is only ever happened one other
time for me
the raincoat
when the doctor suggested surgery and a
brace for all my youngest years my
parents scrambled to take me to massage
therapy deep tissue work osteopathy and
soon my crooked spine unspooled a bit I
could breathe again and move more in a
body unclouded by pain
my mom would tell me to sing songs to
her the whole 45-minute drive to Middle
two Rock Road and 45 minutes back from
physical therapy
she'd say that even my voice sounded
unfettered by my spine afterward so I
sang and sang because I thought she
liked it I never asked her what she gave
up to drive me
or how her day was before this chore
today at her age I was driving myself
home from yet another spine appointment
singing along to some modeling but solid
songs on the radio
and I saw a mom take her raincoat off
and give it to her young daughter when a
storm took over the afternoon
my God I thought
my whole life
I've been under her raincoat
thinking it was somehow a Marvel that I
never got wet
[Applause]
um and then I'll read this poem um
because it was mentioned and you can
hear the poem
that actually this began with a sound
which was
the sound of
recycling bins rolled out all together
and how it sounds like thunder
you know there's like that little moment
where you're like what is that sound
and you're like oh it's like it's it's
like thunder and then you realize it's
just like your neighbor with like the
recycling bin
um of course it's not about that but
that's what that's what sort of
came in my head
dead stars
out here there's a bowing even the trees
are doing Winters I see hand at the back
of all of us black bark slick yellow
leaves a kind of Stillness that feels so
mute it's in another year
I am a hearth of spiders these days a
nest of trying
we point out the stars that make Orion
as we take out the trash the ruling
containers a song of suburban Thunder
it's almost romantic as we adjust the
waxy blue recycling bin until you say
man we should really learn some new
constellations
and it's true
we keep forgetting about antlea
Centaurus Draco laserta Hydra Lira links
but mostly we're forgetting we're dead
stars too
my mouth is full of dust and I wish to
reclaim the rising to lean in the
spotlight of street light with you
towards what law what's larger within us
look we are not on spectacular things
we've come this far survived this much
what would happen if we decided to
survive more
to love harder
what if we stood up with the synapses in
flesh and said no
no to the rising tides
stood for the many mute mouths of the
sea the land what would happen if we
used our bodies to bargain for the
safety of others for Earth if we declare
it a clean night if we stopped being
terrified if we launched our demands
into the sky made ourselves so big
people could point to us with the arrows
they make in their minds rolling their
trash bins out after all of this is over
[Applause]
and I'll read just one more from the
carrying and then I'll move on to the
herding kind
and you guys can hear me okay
okay how are you doing out there
are you good okay good
um
I had this incredible pleasure of
going to Mexico City to be a part of the
Fandango that was a celebration with Dr
Biden and Dr Gutierrez Mueller who's the
first lady of Mexico
um though she doesn't like to be called
the first lady of Mexico she just likes
to be called Dr Gutierrez Mueller
and she sat next to me on stage and read
this poem
in English and I got to see her do that
and it was really emotional for me
so um
this is a poem I wrote as a letter poem
for my dear friend Natalie Diaz
it's the first poem in our series
cargo
I wish I could write to you from
underwater
the warm bath covering my ears
one of which has three marks in the
exact shape of a triangle my own
atmosphere's asterism
last night the fire engine Sirens were
so loud they drowned out even the
constant Bluster of the inbound freight
trains
did you know the RJ Corman railroad runs
500 feet from us
before everything shifted and I aged
into this body my grandparents lived
above San timoteo Canyon where the
Southern Pacific Railroad roared each
scorching California summer day
I watch for the trains howling as they
came
Manuel is in Chicago today and we've
both admitted that we're traveling with
our passports now reports of ice raids
and both of our Bloods are requiring new
medication
I wish I could go back to the windy dock
drinking pink wine and talking smack now
it's gray and pitchfork
the supermarket here is full of grass
seed like spring might actually come but
I don't know
and you
I heard from a friend you're still
working on saving words
all I've been working on is napping
and maybe being kinder to others to
myself
just this morning I saw seven Cardinals
Brash and bold a sin in a leafless tree
I let them be for a long while before I
shook the air and screwed it all up just
by being alive too
am I braver than those birds
do you ever wonder what the trains carry
aluminum ingots plastic brick corn syrup
Limestone Fury alcohol Joy
all the world is moving even sand from
one Shore to another is being shuttled
I live my life half afraid and half
shouting at the trains when they Thunder
by
this letter to you is both
[Applause]
if you were counting
just six more to go
um
begin with this poem
for my stepmother
he passed away in 2010.
um
a lovely human being
and
also one of my favorite plants
which is one of the first signs of
spring it's probably here too you have
forsythia
it's a prose poem so it reads a little
differently I'll read it so you can hear
the sound
for Cynthia
at the cabin in Snug Hollow near McSwain
Branch Creek just spring all the animals
are out and my beloved and I are lying
in bed in a soft silence we are talking
about how we carry so many people with
us wherever we go how even when simply
living these unearned moments are a
tribute to the Dead
we are both expecting to hear an owl as
the night deepens all afternoon from the
porch we watched an Eastern Towhee
furiously build her nest in the Untamed
Forsythia with its yellow spilling out
onto the horizon
I told him that the way I remember the
name Forsythia is that when my
stepmother Cynthia was dying that last
week she said lucidly but mysteriously
more yellow
and I thought yes more yellow and I
nodded because I agreed of course more
yellow and so now in my head when I see
that yellow tangle I say for Cynthia for
Cynthia Forsythia Forsythia more yellow
it is night now and the owl Never Comes
only more of night and what repeats
in the night
[Applause]
that one always does something to me
I say that like someone else wrote it I
was like whoo
that one really gets to me
um let's see
I read a poem um
about
um
rethinking old myths we were talking
about that before and I think that
there's it's important sometimes to just
let go of things that people have told
you or you've held on to that feels like
just not true or maybe just not useful
anymore you know I used to have people
who say oh you always do this and I
think I am like that and then maybe five
years later I was like I I'm not like
that
um and this is a time when uh right when
my parents got divorced I had I had a
woman a mother of a friend of mine come
up and say I'm so sorry you're from a
broken home now
and I remember thinking oh my home is
broken
like I didn't I thought it seemed seemed
okay actually I was like they seem a lot
happier to be honest
um
anyway so right in the middle of the
early days of the pandemic when we still
weren't seeing anyone masked or unmasked
um
this poem came to me with the first line
joint custody
why did I never see it for what it was
abundance
two families two different kitchen
tables two sets of rules two Creeks two
highways two step parents with their
fish tanks or eight tracks or cigarette
smoke or expertise in recipes or reading
skills I cannot reverse it the record
scratched and stopping to that original
chaotic track
but let me say I was taken back and
forth on Sundays
and it was not easy
but I was loved each place
and so I have two brains now
two entirely different brains
the one that always misses where I'm not
and the one that is so relieved to
finally be home
[Applause]
um
and then I'll read this poem you know I
maybe maybe like many of you um if
you're having a bad day or you're
stressed or anxious
[Music]
um
you just watch animal videos
and it's just like you just like push
replay like I need to see that bird
doing that thing again or that cat
eating the most cat food it possibly can
out of the bowl
um
or whales I love just videos of whales
this is one about a mountain lion
and of course oftentimes I say this is
about this and then there's a lot of
other things that are at play I hope I
hope I feel like I'm being very uh you
know um reductress to my own my own
poems
the mountain lion
I watched the video clip over and over
night vision cameras flickering her eyes
and Unholy green
the way she looked the six foot fence up
and down like it was nothing but a speed
bump
then cleared the man-made Border in one
impressive leap
a glance over the shoulder and annoyance
and as if you could keep me out or keep
me in
I don't know what it was that made me
Press replay and replay
not fear though I'd be terrified if I
was face to face with her or heard her
prowling in the night
it was just that I don't think I've ever
made anything look so easy
never looked behind me and grinned or
grimaced because nothing could stop me
I like the idea of it though
felt like a dream you could will into
being
sea offense
jump it
[Applause]
um
I'll I'll read this poem uh
for my
from my grandfather
and
my grandfather on my on my father's side
my paternal grandfather
um Abuelo paternal
and um
he was Puri pecha
and he came from Mexico when he was
quite young and was a foster child and
um
I read this poem because I want to bring
him into this space and also think about
all the people that were artists but
maybe didn't get a chance to be artists
and I think sometimes
we can feel like we're making art and
maybe it's like you know I feel like I
need to keep this poem in my heart when
I'm like running through the airport you
know very glamorous life trying to like
glide into the plane being like don't
leave without me
you know and be like right I'm doing
this because I get to do this
and I think sometimes we need to say
that about lots of things in our lives
heart on fire
as a foster child my grandfather learned
not to get in trouble
Mexican and motherless dead as she was
from tuberculosis he practiced words in
a new language and kept his slender head
down
when the other boys begged him to slip
into the music Shop's upper window to
steal harmonicas for each of them music
being important thievery being secondary
he refused
when the cops came to spot the boys who
robbed the music store they could easily
find the ones spitting broken notes into
the air joyously mouthing the stainless
steel mimicking men on street corners
busking for coins
but not my grandfather
he knew not to risk it all for a stolen
moment of exaltation
it's easy to imagine this is who I come
from a line of serious men who follow
the rules
but might I add that later he was a
dancer a singer an actor whose best
roles ended up on The Cutting Room floor
a cut up a ham who liked a good story
who would have told you life was a
series of warnings but also Magic
once he was sent for a box of matches
and he put that box of strike anywheres
in the pocket of his Madras shirt and
ran home
he ran so fast to be on time to be good
and when he did so the whole box ignited
so he was a boy running down the canyon
road with what looked like a heart on
fire
he'd laugh when he told you this
heart on
he'd say
you'd remember
[Applause]
and then I'll read just three more poems
um
foreign
this is a poem that um
I wrote actually for um
Greenpeace and it was right after the
fires in Sonoma of 2017.
and um
it was on a thread on Twitter and I bet
and the other day and it was all these
apology poems and it was great I just I
went on it on the plane and it was like
all of these people were sharing their
favorite poems that had apologies in
them
and I was like what a great you're going
to teach a whole course on just like an
apology poem
so I thought I would read this because
it reminded me of my own poem
Salvage
on the top of Mount Pisgah on the
western slope of the mayakomas there's a
madrone tree that's half burned from the
fires
half alive from Nature's need to
propagate
one side of her is black ash
and at her root is what looks like a
cavity hollowed out by Flame
on the other side
silvery green broadleaf shoots Ascend
toward the winter light and her bark is
a cross between a bay horse and a
chestnut horse red and velvety like the
animal's neck she resembles
staring at the tree for a long time now
I am reminded of the righteousness I had
before The Scorch of time
I miss who I was
I miss who we all were before we were
this half alive to the brightening Sky
half dead already
I place my hand on the unscarred bark
that is cool and unsullied and because I
cannot apologize to the tree to my own
self I say
I am sorry
I am sorry I have been so reckless with
your life
and
[Applause]
um
let's see here I'll read uh this poem
it's another prose poem
have do you guys know the instrument the
Jawbone
it's an actual Jawbone I have a horse or
a donkey and
it makes the most amazing music
instrumentation
if I could ever play an instrument for
real I like the idea of playing the
Jawbone the rattle of something dead in
your hands the thing that beats back at
the sky and says I'm still here
even though clearly the donkey isn't
here
or the horse isn't here
just the teeth and the jaw making music
like Resurrection or haunting or just
plain need
what I like most is that the Jawbone is
an idiophone which I misread once as
ideaphone but an idiophone is just that
it makes music by the whole thing
vibrating without strings
I want that
that kind of reeling in the wind all the
loose dry teeth all the old bones of the
skull all the world and the figure
swaying with its stick to make untuned
music even death cannot deny
and I'll close with this poem and then
if you have any questions you can ask
um this is a poem that I wrote during
the very early days of the pandemic and
um people would call me and ask me about
you know isn't it true that we need
poetry now more than ever and I was like
is that true
we like we need lots of things
health care and
a vaccine
and um
you know
different modes of support
[Laughter]
but while this was happening I was also
making a list of of subjects that I felt
like I'm sure many of you who are
writers know this feeling where I've
already written about that I can't write
it again or I've done that before or and
so it just became this list of of things
in my head
and then
of course what happened was it turned
into a poem
the end of poetry
enough of osseus and chickadee and
sunflower and snowshoes Maple and seeds
Samurai and shoot enough kyoscuro enough
of thus and prophecy and the stoic
farmer and faith in our father and Tis
of Thee enough of bosom and Bud skinned
in God not forgetting and star bodies
and Frozen Birds enough of the will to
go on or not go on or how a certain
light does a certain thing
enough of the kneeling and the rising
and the looking Inward and the looking
up enough of the gun the drama and the
acquaintance of suicide the long-lost
letter on the dresser enough of the
longing and the ego and the obliteration
of ego enough of the mother and the
child and the father and the child and
enough of the pointing to the world
weary and desperate enough of the brutal
and the Border enough of can you see me
can you hear me enough I am human enough
I am alone and I am desperate enough of
the animal saving me enough of the high
water enough sorrow enough of the air
and its ease I am asking you to touch me
thank you
[Applause]
a few minutes before six will key to
that this last question or two if you
have a question
I know it's pressure because it's like a
microphone and it's right there
[Laughter]
oh yes A Brave One
what is your favorite poem
my favorite poem of all time
that's a great question
it changes because sometimes I need a
certain poem and that poem becomes my
favorite and then sometimes I need
another poem but I think Elizabeth
Bishop's one art might be my favorite
poem
thank you for that
[Applause]
is this working oh okay
this is so satisfying
um hi
um first of all like this reading is
like the highlight of my week so I'm so
glad thank you thank you
um
it was amazing especially like the last
poem I think like like there's this
Instagram account called like poetry
it's not luxury and I'm pretty sure I
feel like I saw that on there and
um now I want to read more um but like
anyways so like to get to the point
um
I'm wondering
um what you think
about cliches and like what the role of
cliches has been your work and
um if there's ever a point where you're
just like
have I written everything I will ever
write
um for like
for the end of time
um like how do you pick yourself up from
this space that like
um
like like artistic paralysis
um and like working with cliches or
maybe working with like being more
direct in your poetry um and like maybe
swapping figurative language for just
like this is how I'm feeling this really
right now
um and I just need to like
get it out on a page yeah that's a great
question I really appreciate that I'll
say that there's two things that I'll
say is that one I feel like um
it's all about interrogation
so it's so it feels to me like when
there's a moment where I'm just saying
the direct thing or it feels direct I
ask myself like is that direct is that
the thing or is there more going on and
sometimes the figurative language comes
into that or the imagistic language or
maybe it just needs sounds or something
that will actually explain it further or
elucidate it more so that it's not just
the feeling anymore or the
straightforward thing but that it builds
into something that's just my own and
that is something so it's like always
asking the thing you know is this true
is this really is this true and then the
other part I would say is that
especially with cliches is that I love
cliches I think they're wonderful and
they exist for a reason and then what's
really fun about them is to tug them and
pull them apart to start going like okay
so why why do we say you know I have a
poem that's about like a that idea of
like it's always in the last place you
you look you know and how how silly that
is say go well of course it is because
you found it you know but like and and
and so I but I like the poem you know
sometimes just taking a cliche that
someone says and then pulling it apart
and looking at it in my book bright dead
things I have a poem called down-hearted
and it's about this idea of like you
know picturing the heart actually down
in the in like that it's sunk to the
bottom of your torso that's down-hearted
and that's you know on a couch with
pulling up the blankets over its head so
I think sometimes it's just about
interrogating the cliche and then
breaking it apart
oh thank you so much yeah of course
[Applause]
I had a class and I showed up very late
so I apologize if I'm out of breath and
if this was covered um at the start but
um as someone who's not a poet um and
sort of admires poets
um
could you describe a little bit what the
editing process specifically for a poet
of your caliber looks like because I
think
in the few
interactions I've had with poets my age
who are very talented it feels very
different than prose editing and also
my imagine tells me my imagination tells
me that at least when I'm editing prose
I kind of know what I'm writing out
writing about from the beginning but
poetry if you like there are times when
a New Day brings sort of A New
Perspective a new image
um right what does that look like yeah
that's great I think maybe how do you
know when a poem is done which also
feels more tricky than perhaps yeah
these are both great questions revision
to me is actually
um I think really fun but it is it is
primarily where the writing happens in
poetry because we're working with such
tiny units you know it's so small that
everything is compressed and everything
is you know sort of vibrating with the
intensity of that white space around it
that silence around it so that you know
it has to become you know some sometimes
it feels like you have like a tweezer
and you're like just like moving pieces
of rice around the page but they're very
important pieces of rice you know but I
think um for me a lot of it's about the
sound quality
um and so I have I compose out loud and
I edit out loud so that I'm reading the
poem over and over again I'm listening
for places where I've I've either cut
the line too short and the breath
doesn't catch up with it or I stumble on
it each time or I'm looking for a place
where I'm like oh this is actually
um you know I I love sound work so it's
easy for me to kind of get into the you
know consonants and assonance and you
know all the fun alliteration things and
then maybe like okay calm down Ada you
know like you don't need to you know do
acrobatics right now just just move move
the machine forward
um so a lot of that of sound work and
then the other part is looking to figure
out if like what like when you asked
about you know coming to it like a
different day and being like well what
was the intention or you know oftentimes
I'm asking okay what what is the
intention of this original poem like
what this original draft and how can I
stay true to what the poem wants to do
without it becoming just sort of where I
want it to go or maybe I started with
this idea that I wanted to write a poem
about this but then the poem wanted to
do something entirely different and
usually what happens is when I revise
and I fail it's because I'm like no no I
wanted to write a poem about this but
I'm not looking at what the poem is
actually doing
and the poem is often wiser than we are
and it feels like the poem really isn't
happening until it has taught us
something which the opposite of prose
where you start with this idea you know
and you're like okay I kind of kind of
know where I'm going even though you of
course you learn as you go and that's
why we write but there is this level in
which with the poem it really does
sometimes just come at you and go oh
I didn't know that this was what it was
supposed to teach me
um and so I think that moment has to
happen and that's also similar to like
how I know it's done is that there's
something that feels maybe not like a
conclusion but a wholeness a
completeness something that feels like
uh whatever it began as it has fulfilled
yeah thank you so much thank you
hi thank you for being here I have a
related question I read somewhere and I
hope this is true and I'm not making it
up that you started to write fiction and
realized somehow that you were a poet
and not a fiction writer and I'd love to
hear more about that moment and what
that felt like and what exactly tipped
you into that conclusion okay so not
entirely off base
but I'll say this is that I had three I
was always a poet I had three books out
and then I decided I wanted to try my
hand at fiction and so I you know quit
my job and I was like I'm gonna be a
full-time writer
that which I don't know why I thought I
could do that but um I guess it turned
out okay actually
um but I I moved out of New York and
moved back to California and I did write
a novel
um well I mean many drafts of a failed
novel or a
um
project that I learned a lot from
and
um as I was writing that novel what
happened was I was spending so much time
in the life of other characters which I
wanted to do because after three books
of poetry I was like okay I that's like
enough of myself right and then what
happened was then during the evenings I
would still kind of feel like writing
something but I would want to write
these observations I would run and write
a little bit about myself and that's
really how the first book or the it's
the fourth book bright dead things came
into being which was it was almost like
a byproduct of like this novel I was
working on because I was storing up all
these poems inside of me and they would
just come out like fully formed all the
time
um
so yeah so you're not it was I would
always start it as a poet but I did that
book does really kind of uh take some of
its life form from from the novel thank
you yeah of course
[Applause]
um hi there thank you so much for being
here and doing this this was really
lovely yeah thank you
um I was wondering
um in your your appointment is Poet
Laureate and all the books you've had
I'd imagine those are very codifying
experiences in sort of your identity as
a poet and as a writer and so I was
wondering what sort of inspired you to
keep creating and to keep writing in
moments when you've maybe had more doubt
about your place as a writer as a
creative person
yeah you know I think that there's a lot
of times where it's very easy to get
down on oneself no matter what you do
you know
um and it happens to me still and
there's moments where I think oh well
now that this appointment you know uh
has happened I'll never write again you
know it's very easy for me to turn
anything into I'll just never write
again
um and sometimes like if I write a poem
I'm really excited about and people are
like this is great you know and as soon
as I I get very elated you know I pour
myself a cocktail and two seconds later
I'm like well I guess that's the last
poem I've ever written like I just I I
don't know what it is so I think we all
do it we have this kind of self-talk
that just is like you know and um I
think as I have aged I do think I've
trusted it like now it's like okay I'm
six books in it they will come and they
work in seasons and I work in Seasons so
that now I trust the silence so that if
it isn't coming I just think it's gonna
come and it's gonna come you know for me
I love writing in the spring you know
it's like it's so right now you know all
the trees are kind of they're sleeping
they're they're starting to figure out
what they're what they're gonna do you
know that's kind of where I'm at and
then things will come so it's a lot
about trusting that I think the other
thing I think about is that
when people say you know
how could you write through a time like
this or how it's like really hard right
now or this I think about like you know
Phyllis Wheatley writing as an enslaved
woman you know I think about uh
you sir Juanita De La Cruz writing you
know in Mexico all those years ago and
like holding her manuscript in my hands
thinking this is what she created at
this time so I'm always like trying to
look at like the legacy of others and
how that can Inspire us especially when
I feel myself kind of getting down on
you know either myself or art in general
and you know and and I always pull
myself up by thinking about how many
people have done so much in such
harrowing times
thank you thank you
hi thank you so much for being here
today thank you I had a question about
your background in theater because
theater is so much about I guess
becoming a different character and
becoming a different person whereas
poetry is about honesty and
in theater you want to sound natural and
up on stage but in poetry sometimes we
like to play with language and do
different things so what was that
transition like from you and what do you
do you think theater influences how you
write poetry or vice versa that's a
great question
um I have never once um regretted my
undergraduate degree in theater it was a
great experience for me I searched on
campus I went to the University of
Washington in Seattle and I remember you
know I had come from a town that was 30
000 people and I went to a campus that
was 40 000 people and I was like this is
you know I don't know where are my
people I didn't know I didn't know what
to do and I remember sort of walking
into the theater department and everyone
was like just sort of running around and
like Barefoot and laughing and someone
was like singing opera in the corner and
I was like oh I think I'm along here
and um and it just felt like this we
were you know everyone was a little bit
everyone was interested in making things
and um I think that was actually
probably more healthy for me at the time
than it was in
um the creative writing program because
I didn't have that background it was a
little more you know
um
I I think it would have been too
intimidating and it might have even put
me off
um but so for me I think one of the big
things was that theater teaches you
about breath it teaches you about
communication and it teaches you about
what it is to sort of stand in your
being you know and be present and you
know the best Stage actors can do that
and really embody someone else
and I think the other part of it was
doing monologues really taught me a lot
about what it was to write something
that could turn and twist and move in
such a short in a short space
um and then the last thing I'll say is
that um
when I did take poetry in my Junior and
senior years because I had exhausted the
electives I could take inside the
theater program they were like you need
to move on
um I went and I took I took these
classes and I was like
oh I love this and I had also realized
that for the most part I was speaking
the words of others right that's what
theater is and I was also at that time
really primarily working with the words
of older white men
um and so it felt like I had this
opportunity to then write myself into
the world
and that felt like a it really felt like
freedom and I think once I found that
kind of freeing space I thought okay
poetry said
thank you so much
thank you hi I'm wondering what your
relationship is like to the speaker of
your poems and if
six books in that's changed for you
yeah that's a great question I think in
order to sort of protect each other as
we talk about work we always use the you
know the speaker the speaker in the poem
is doing this the speaker in the poem is
this and you know when I sit down to the
page I'm always I'm the speaker
you know and so I I I I feel like it's
okay to complete the two I think
sometimes it's it's it's nice to
separate that when we talk about someone
else's work or even if we need to for
ourselves like the speaker is doing this
um for the most part I'm very
comfortable with with it just being me
um and feeling in some ways that
actually the more human I can get on the
page the more interesting the poem might
be for myself as I'm making it
um so I'm trying to actually look for a
little even more intimacy beyond the
word speaker
um
but that doesn't mean sometimes I still
want to keep it as self-protection
hi
um thank you so much for the beautiful
reading thank you um I just wanted to
ask as someone who I find
um needs poetry to properly enjoy life
and love life
um have you ever had and someone who
finds it difficult when I can't write
what I need to write or I am afraid to
have you ever had moments in which you
feel like you need to write something
but you can't or you are afraid to write
something and how did you get through
that and how did that feel yeah that's a
great question
um yeah there have definitely been times
where I felt like I haven't wanted to
write something
um or felt like I shouldn't write
something who am I to write that or
how might this do harm to that those I
love
um that's probably one of the biggest
things is like could this harm someone
close to me
um is it my story to tell or is it a
joint story right is it a family story
that's not just mine
there's a lot of those questions of
ethics and I'll be honest that I don't
think we talk about it enough because I
think that what happens is sometimes we
as writers are like I'm the writer I
should be able to have all the freedom I
want to write about whatever I want
which is a beautiful thing if you're not
a human being that lives with other
human beings
or if you've never had a human
relationship then that's fine but I
think that you know if we want our
writing to have impact then we also have
to be aware that writing can have
consequences and I think that we
actually should learn that because you
can write the hard thing
but unless you're ready to have that
conversation
then don't share it
you might need to write it for yourself
and you might need to put it in a drawer
and I know lots of incredible poets who
have written books upon books that are
on shelves
and will probably be published when
someone passes away
and I think that that's okay and I think
that unless you're ready to like sort of
do some deep deeper excavation or you're
ready to approach whatever subject it is
that might be terrifying you
um then you may not be ready to share it
with the world and that is okay forcing
it it never works it never works so I
think it's it's always good again the
goal is longevity right we want you to
write and we want you to keep writing we
don't want you to write and be like oh
well that was traumatic let's not do
that again
yeah so I think it's always a way of
protecting yourself encouraging yourself
but making sure that you continue
thank you so much
I'm probably like the 100th participants
person to say thank you but thank you
for coming
um you were talking about earlier at the
beginning how you push back against the
myth of making art alone and I well
um and I wanted to ask if there was ever
if it was a if there was a moment or if
there was a process that made you
realize that it was a myth because I
feel like it's very it's very easy to
succumb to it yeah it's much harder to
internalize that that feeling also
what's your Pug's name yeah
well first of all my pug is named Lily
Bean Kudzu marquart Limon
and
um she is amazing
and um she used to travel with me but
she's 12 now and I feel like she just
with all she does is snore and sleep and
it would just be actually distracting
because her snore is so loud
um but yeah she uh she's fantastic
um okay the other question I just got
distracted by my pug
um remind me what you just said before
that right see I got distracted my pug
it's okay it happens to me too uh just
if there was a moment or specific oh yes
yes you know what it was it was that you
know you you sort of you read literary
literary biographies or you you look at
these you know poets that have hung out
together or novelists or artists and you
realize like oh all these people were
hanging out together you know where like
someone's like you you know you meet
with someone and they're like oh yeah no
that was my teacher you know I was like
I always loved mirror Kaiser and I
remember I studied with Sharon Olds and
Sharon Olds was like yeah I'm your work
eyes are with my teacher and I was like
oh right like this is this is what this
is like there are so many cycles and so
many communities and we think of like
you know so and so being on a pedestal
or this and that and I just I don't
think it's true and then the other thing
is that it's like yes do we have to
actually do the work alone
yeah you know for the most part you do
that's actually one of the things I like
about it because it takes a lot to do
theater it takes a lot of people to make
theater I get to do my art alone in my
house in my slippers you know so I think
there is that part but I think it's
really
um I think it was that moment was in
graduate school it's just watching
everyone kind of come together and and
be in community I didn't have that in
the creative writing as an undergrad I
had that in theater but I didn't know it
in Korea writing but yeah it came as a
graduate school great thank you so much
thank you
hi hi uh thank you so much again uh this
is great thank you
so I wanted to ask
um I'm going to generalize a lot so I
apologize but I I notice in your poetry
that on one hand you read a lot a lot
about the body and on the other hand a
lot about nature and I was wondering how
you conceptualize the relationship
between the two you know is it a
boundary is it a continuity is it a
mirror like is it all of those things or
none of those things yeah
I love that question I think for me it
all kind of depends on the day
you know sometimes I'm like oh this
feels like I am in Tandem and connected
to everything and sometimes I feel like
oh I am a machine that is walking around
doing things with a head full of
thoughts that is very separate right and
I'm always trying to bring them together
and then there are moments where I feel
like oh I am just as much animal as that
squirrel and why am I wearing clothes
because it's weird that we're animals
that we're close
so all of those things
hi thank you so much for coming and your
reading was really moving I was reading
the hurting kind like a few days ago in
the at the basement of one of our
libraries and I remember sitting there
for 10 minutes but
um I kind of wanted to ask about your
writing and
um partly because I think a lot of what
you write about resonates with me in
themes of grief and loss and sometimes
as a poet I personally
have had issues like writing about grief
or loss that isn't my own so the only
time I have been able to write or
express myself or release my pain has
been through poetry but it has been hard
for me to reconstruct someone else's
pain and then write about it and so I
was wondering like is that something
you've done is that something you find
an Avenue of poetry from and yeah just
one of your thoughts yeah I think for me
for the most part when I'm dealing with
agree for a lost poem
um it it feels like it it's it's either
very personal or it's very
um Collective
and I have to have some part of that
that belongs to me some part of it that
feels like oh this is also mine
um and whether that's National grief you
know whether that's communal grief
um and so I have to find my thread and
connection to it if it's someone else as
I may not approach it that's me as an
artist
um and that's also because I'm very wary
of appropriating someone else's pain in
order to perpetuate art
um not everyone feels that way
but I do so I feel like there's a way in
which that I it has to feel like it's
some thread of it belongs to me enough
so that I can have an intimate
experience in the making of it and that
I feel urgently connected to it
um otherwise it might feel a little too
much like a um like a project or a
manipulation
yeah thank you so much yeah thank you
[Applause]
thank you for coming and um kind of
similar to the last question of um
having experiences of grief and pain and
loss but then wanting to have those
experiences go up at the same time
wanting to
like
create and how there's this like
situation where you want to let go but
then you also want to
create something fantastic and how do
you basically how do you deal with that
problem yeah
um I think that for me that is it it's
it to me that's a you have to get
curious
so I I find myself in those situations
asking myself
what is it that once to hold on to this
why this moment
why did this person come back to me
right now
why does this feel almost like
you know something worth living for this
pain
I'm I have to get very curious about
those things and it's asking yourself
okay
is there's a lesson here
is there something that this is supposed
to teach me what's the gift I got from
this
you know it's starting to ask those
questions about those those losses
um and in doing so unraveling why it is
that they're so instrumental to Who We
Are
thank you yeah
hi oh my god
um
so you mentioned your friend of yours
named Natalie Diaz and am I correct in
assuming that's the author of
post-colonial love poem yes love that
book love yours as well yeah she um
she has so postcolonial has the other
set of the poems that are written to
each other yeah that's fantastic yeah
I'll go for it but there's this line
from post-colonial love poem that I
think about always and I'm definitely
not going to be quoting it word for word
but it goes something like it is real
work not to perform a fable just ask the
turtle ask the hair and I kind of wanted
to ask you whose poems I've read and
seem so free and liberating and have
these this sense of reverence for what
is small both small and beautiful and I
kind of wanted to ask how you negotiate
those terms as someone who maybe does
exist in within the marginalized and
yeah just as a writer myself I would
love to emulate some of those freedoms
and yeah hear your process yeah I think
that's really beautiful and it's a great
question to end on because I think it's
really essential to how we all work I
think that as I mentioned earlier about
like how I like to push against like the
unhelpful myths right the things that
are like this is not helpful to me it's
not useful to me I think in the same way
that as soon as someone wants to tell me
that I need to write about some specific
thing I will immediately be like no I do
not need to do that and there's this
like wickedness in me that immediately
wants to deny any part of like when
someone is like oh you know you're a
Mexican so we you know where's your
abuela poem or your you know all of
these things and immediately I'm like no
no no no no I'm gonna write about this
tree and that's what I'm going to write
about you know and then sometimes like
you know six years later I'll be like
okay here's my grandpa poem or here's my
grandma poem but you know there's these
these ways in which that I think I I'm
very uh I'm very suspicious
of what is asked of us especially as
writers of color and how we get put into
categories that don't have anything to
do with beauty Joy hope and freedom
and I'm very suspicious of the people
who want to publish trauma bias that
want to publish they'll you know only
you know write to us when you have the
Border story write to us when this and
this and this and this it's like well
what if I what if I don't have any even
signifiers in there would you be
interested if it was good work
right so I I'm always pushing against it
and I think it doesn't mean I don't
interrogate it in my own work it doesn't
mean it's not there but to me it feels
uh I you know I grew up at a time as a
writer where every poem that was
published by a black man in a certain
Journal would always had to have a
bullet in it in order to get published
right and if it you were you know if you
were latinx you were you might you
better have a rose compoyo like it was
like this very and it was like oh my God
this is in these big journals that I
shouldn't name but
and it you know and and I and I saw that
and I remember very early on being like
I want everyone else's freedom and guess
what they can't give it to me I can only
take it for myself
thank you that was wonderful
[Applause]
thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]